so he's on the road and new data from
the U.S Customs and Border Protection
showing illegal Crossings jumped over 30
percent last month the recent surge
becoming a campaign point for South
Carolina Senator Tim Scott as he makes
his first trip to the Border as a
presidential candidate and he joins me
now Senator I know that you went to the
Border in 2019. how what did you learn
that's different now what did you see
that's different what disturbs you what
do you think could be fixed
well Dana the the biggest difference
between 2019 and now two words Joe Biden
when you have a president who unleashes
an unopened wide open unsafe insecure
border we cannot be surprised by more
than 6 million illegal Crossings however
the devastation of seventy thousand
Americans who lost their lives to
fentanyl because Joe Biden refuses to
close our Southern border preventable
as president of the United States I will
finish this wall and I will use the
available technology to surveil our
border to stop fentanyl from killing
another 70 000 Americans in the next 12
months did you have a chance to talk to
us to some local people there and what
do they make of this recent surge we can
pull up call for number one July
compared to June there were 130 000
arrests in July there were only a
hundred about a hundred thousand in June
so there's a that's a pretty traumatic
uptick what do they put that down to
because the Biden Administration says
that they've been doing a pretty good
job
well the by Administration continues to
tell the American people believe what we
say and not what you see with your own
eyes I've had an opportunity already to
speak with law enforcement they tell me
that the surge continues I will meet
after we leave the border right now with
uh Community leaders and frankly with
folks who lost their kids to fentanyl
the devastation that we are experiencing
as Americans is preventable much of it
is preventable if we finish the wall use
technology fire Joe Biden and hire me I
will be the president that finishes the
wall and takes seriously the opportunity
to save tens of thousands of Americans
from the drug of fentanyl fentanyl is a
huge issue and it's not an issue just
there at the border right it's happening
all across the country and just in the
last question I have for you for four
months I believe from the day that Iowa
voters will go to the polls and then New
Hampshire's of course right after that
so this is getting real and it's getting
real very fast the latest poll here from
The New York Times Siena poll showed
Trump at 54 percent DeSantis at 17 and
Pence Scott and Haley at 3 percent now I
know that the voting hasn't started yet
the debate hasn't happened yet but these
numbers are making people starting to
feel like is this an impossible
situation for any of those candidates
who want to challenge Donald Trump
not at all what I'm excited about is in
Iowa we're already in third place we
continue to see our poll numbers move
but we are understanding every single
day is that the voters in Iowa want an
optimistic positive message anchored in
conservatism as long as you have a
backbone the more we meet people the
more excited we are about the future of
this campaign the good news is we've not
yet started the Sprint we're still in
the long journey the Sprint starts in
the fourth quarter I'm excited that
we'll be at the finish line and we'll
get there first January the 14th they
were mixing Sports metaphors there and I
with it
if you're a fourth quarter and you're
Finish Line all right Senator Tim Scott
thank you absolutely thank you I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis